imagine em playin on this but
boom-boom-boom-boom
[Music]
what's so attractive about the butt so
it's you got the cusp around this you
got the plumpness it's it goes it's a
lot you can do with the booty but to
replicate your favorite fruit peaches
plums pears - grapes grapes are good
kind of like a sweet apple you know you
just want to look at it and just bite
right into it you never know what fruit
you're gonna get out of the salad so
it's kind of cool I have never felt a
budding plane before neither have I
honestly I don't know if it's good I'm
just afraid that it's gonna feel so much
like the real thing I won't be able to
tell what's real and what's fake anymore
I want them to be like the boob implants
where they're currently when we discuss
buttock implants there is really one
type of implant and that is a silicone
buttock implant the outer shell is made
of silicone and the inner part is a
thicker type of silicone which is
similar to a breast implant these
implants are not just strictly for women
obviously there are men out there who
are going to the gym who are looking for
more volume for firm buttocks miss
stigma of having plastic surgery is
certainly no longer what it used to be
oh oh it's hard as hell I'm more like a
teardrop I mean that's not really a
pillow but I don't think so
oh I would actually like to wear these
on that because it's like I don't have
that uncomfortable sensation it's like
I'm always sitting in their sofa I
didn't know we're gonna add some right
this is what I look like sitting down on
a regular right this is not looking good
but anyway yeah I do this girl's crazy
I'm gonna have to get somebody implants
just by height purposes
oh she's curvy this is way better for my
this that ass is the grave test yeah
this is what I was imagining
looks like the popular it's kind of cool
I like it it kind of fits right in your
palm it's like you know you know like
the follows best well commercials what
it's like Michael Jordan just gripping
the ball that's skin wrinkles are pretty
small wow it's like that it sounds like
a real butt yeah that one that was nice
i but i like the way that this one feels
yeah so i guess like if you like looks
over the feel maybe this one hold on
your hands what do you think it feels
like really gross
yeah this looks like very chiseled a
chisel in fact is this for like you want
that saggy effect it also feels like one
of those mouth yeah like learning
experience for me I didn't know there
were so many different kinds of but
anyway I was just surprised at how much
it didn't look like my image of butt
implants yeah no not what I expected at
all if there is one thought in your mind
about getting a butt implant you make
sure you do your homework you make sure
you sample everything out you talk to
people with butt implants you feel their
butts you get completely ready do it
makes you happy
put more fat in your butt or don't put
more fat in you but we're do more squats
or don't do more squat do you boo boo do
you all about said oh that's our cute
oh that's our an amazing gift to this
planet
[Music]